là je vous propose pour terminer cette
édition de la terminer effectivement
avec la grande guinguette 1900 au bord
de l'eau une manifestation qui se
déroule à quelques mètres de ce studio
et ce depuis le début de l'après midi
bonne soirée à tous et merci d'avoir
suivi cette émission oui cette fête a
commencé cet après-midi sous le soleil
est au milieu de la verdure
elle continuera à ce soir par un bal
musette agrémenté d'un concours de
maillots de bain de la belle époque
demain la fête se poursuivra au bord et
sur l'eau avec un tiercé de bouteilles à
la mer une course de ski de fond
nautique une démonstration de
canoë-kayak des promenades en bateau et
puis pour ceux qui n'ont pas le pied
particulièrement marin le spectacle sera
aussi presque permanent et gratuit sur
le podium installé sur les berges des
chances de la danse des danses de la
belle époque comme celle que vous
propose maintenant les nattes ours
d'harmonie
vous
m
oui
où
venu
m